today i'm going to change your life i'm
going to take you from the office nobody
to the archicad shortcut expert everyone
relies on what's going on guys my name
is david tomic and welcome back to the
channel today i'm going to teach you all
of the arcade shortcuts that are
fundamental and essential to make you
the shortcut king or queen in your
office i will quickly warn you that this
video will be relatively jumpy but there
is an easter egg in the middle if you
pay close attention so without further
ado let's turn around to these two
screens and get started now that we have
archived 25 open brand new fresh
template nothing really else that is out
of the ordinary we're going to start by
running through the absolute basic
shortcuts and working through about
three pages worth of incredible
shortcuts both for mac and windows that
if you stick around i'm going to tell
you exactly how you can download a pdf
copy of all of this information so you
don't have to keep coming back watching
this video over and over again starting
arcade with the most basic shortcuts
command or control plus the letter n is
going to automatically open up a new
project template command option n or
control alt n is going to prompt you
with a save box basically what you're
doing here is if you go don't save it's
going to open up a 100
completely blank template so there's
going to be nothing on here all the
settings are going to be reverted back
to bare bones
this isn't something that i recommend
very often so if you are starting a new
arcade template it's always control n
and use whatever template is available
to you command or control o is going to
open up whatever file you want plus
control or command w is going to close
that particular project but still leave
archicad running in the background if
instead you press command or control q
it will close archicad entirely whilst
prompting you to save that project
before you do so just like in every
other program control s or command s is
to save your project command shift or
control shift plus s is save as control
z is going to undo your last action
control or command z is going to undo
your last action so if i quickly draw a
slab ctrl z
undo ctrl shift z or command shift z
will redo that same action command a is
going to highlight everything in your
project at once whilst command shift a
is going to allow you to actually locate
the project file or the window that
you're looking for basically everything
that is open at the top is going to open
up in a grid view here on your screen
when you press command or control shift
a command b is going to actually repeat
your last command so if i did command d
over here and then press command b again
it would repeat that same command
command c very simple copy command v
very simple paste in archicad you have
to click once more outside the dash line
to finalize your paste elements so if i
drag that across we have two identical
elements delete very simple we'll delete
anything you have selected control or
command f is going to open up your find
and select template box if you want to
get a copy of this pdf shortcut you can
download it from my website it is 100
free for you to download at no cost to
you whatsoever all you have to do is go
down to the description below click on
the link and wait five seconds for the
pop-up to appear i designated five
seconds because i didn't want to pass to
you guys if you're shopping for
something else as we all know people
don't spend five seconds on a website so
if you do want this template scroll down
click the link wait five seconds put
your email in and it will be sent to
your inbox within a matter of seconds
now in archive25 they've actually
removed a very useful command which i'm
going to show you exactly how to
reinstate so if we come up to options
work environment and scroll down to
keyboard shortcuts we can reinstate a
very popular shortcut what i'm going to
do is now scroll down in the current
subsection menu structure to find
hotlink and hotlink manager now you can
find that under external content
pressing on place hotlink assign the
control plus apostrophe or command plus
apostrophe go assign anyway to override
the existing currently assigned
shortcut press ok and repeat that same
step so options work environment
keyboard shortcuts external content
hotlink module manager and then we are
going to go control shift apostrophe and
reassign anyway and press ok so now if
we press the control and apostrophe
button it's going to open up our place
hotlink window whilst control shift and
the apostrophe button is our hotlink
module manager moving into the drawing
section of these shortcuts if you've got
an item selected you can press control
or command d to automatically move it
control or command e to open up the
rotate tool command h to stretch that
section along command m to automatically
activate the mirror tool command k to
resize anything you have selected by
simply following the typical resize
proportion style and finally command t
to open up the actual settings of the
item you have selected command shift d
allows you to drag and copy immediately
without having to press command shift
and then tapping the control button as
an alternative command shift e
automatically allows you to copy and
rotate at the same time command g allows
you to group elements while command
shift g allows you to ungroup those same
elements that you've just grouped
together if you have objects grouped
together and you only wish to select one
portion of that group you can press alt
or option g depending on your system to
suspend and unsuspend those groups last
but not least moving into the
fundamentals of the background scene if
you press control or command up you'll
move along the story settings as you see
here on the right hand panel
same thing is effective if you press the
down arrow as well if you're using a
mouse that doesn't have a scroll wheel
it's also effective to know that you can
press the control and the square
brackets in and out as an option to zoom
in and out to your objects anyway that's
all for me today guys thank you so much
for watching i hope you enjoyed the
video i hope you got some valuable
content and some valuable information
out of it if you did smash the like
button smash the subscribe button and as
always i'll see you next monday